so Shane Dawson who is famously horrible
literally warned us about Colleen
Ballinger Circa 2015. this is a clip
that resurfaced oh my gosh Halloween is
the best because she needs 10 of these
fans she is the most hateful shadiest I
love her like whenever we hang out oh
wait you love her this is the most
hateful Shady piece of I've ever
known I love her I love her literally
the first words out of her mouth are
okay like what do you got who do you
hate who's next like just going in on
everybody holy crap you gotta get her
out here oh I would love to wait Shane I
don't think that
it sounds like you love her maybe bad
traits we're describing yeah that's not
like a nice way to describe your friend
I believe you
certainly yeah like a lot of the comedy
comes from hate self-hatred when you
hate yourself you hate everybody around
you by the way I hate that Trope that's
just I hate when people say
stuff like that Harmony the only the way
be funny is to hate yourself bro and be
miserable and sad all the time